it's fascinating that feminism and
communism and all these things happen in
the 20th century so many interesting
things happen in the 20th century so
many movements so many ideas nuclear
weapons all of it computers it's just
like it seems like a lot of stuff like
really quickly percolated and it's
accelerating it's still accelerating I
mean history is just accelerating you
know for centuries and uh the 20th
century you know you we squeezed into it
the things that previously took
thousands of years and now I mean we are
squeezing it into decades and you very
well could be one of the last historians
human historians to have ever lived
could be I I think you know our species
Homo sapiens I don't think we'll be
around in a century or two we could
destroy ourselves
in a nuclear war through ecological
collapse uh by giving too much power to
AI that goes out out of our control
but if we survive we'll probably have so
much power that we will change ourselves
using various Technologies uh so that
our descendants will no longer be Homo
sapiens like us they will be more
different from us than we are different
from Neanderthals
um so maybe the they'll have historians
but it will no longer be human
historians or sapiens historians like me
I think it's an extremely dangerous uh
uh development and the chances that this
will go wrong that will this will you
people will use the new technologies
trying to upgrade humans but actually
downgrading them this is a very very big
danger if you let corporations and
armies and ruthless politicians
uh change humans using tools like Ai and
bioengineering it's very likely that
they will try to enhance a few human
qualities that they need
like intelligence and discipline
while neglecting
what are potentially more important
human qualities like compassion
like autistic sensitivity like
spirituality if you give Putin for
instance
bioengineering and Ai and brain computer
interfaces he is likely to want to
create a race of our super soldiers
who are much more intelligent and much
more stronger and also much more
disciplined and never Rebel and March on
Moscow against him but he has no
interest in making them more
compassionate or more spiritual
so the end result could be a a a new
type of humans a downgraded humans who
are highly intelligent and disciplined
but have no compassion and no spiritual
depth and this is one for me this is you
know the dystopia the Apocalypse
that when people talk about the new
technologies and they have this scenario
of you know the Terminator robot trying
industry shooting people this is not
what worries me I think we can avoid
that what really worries me is using the
the corporations armies politicians will
use the new technologies
to change us in a way which will destroy
our Humanity or the best parts of our
humanity and one of those ways could be
removing the compassion another way that
really worries me for me is probably
more likely is a Brave New World kind of
thing that uh
uh sort of removes the flaws of humans
maybe it removes the diversity in humans
and makes us all kind of uh these
dopamine chasing creatures that just
kind of maximize enjoyment in the short
term which kind of
seems like a good thing maybe in the
short term but it's it creates a society
that doesn't think that doesn't create
that just is sitting there
enjoying itself
at a more and more rapid pace which uh
seems like another kind of society that
could be easily controlled by a
centralized Center of power but the set
of dystopias that we could arrive at
through this
um
through a long corporations to modify
humans is uh uh is vast and we should be
worried about that so it's it seems like
humans are
pretty good as we are all the flaws all
of it together we are better than
anything that we can intentionally
design at present yeah like any
intentionally designed humans at the
present moment
is going to be much much worse than us
because basically we don't understand
ourselves I mean as long as we don't
understand our brain our body our mind
it's a very very bad idea to start
manipulating A system that you don't
understand deeply and we don't
understand ourselves